[Music]
alright guys I have and [ __ ] [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] oh we're all doing it oh [ __ ]
lenses guest host guest host I'm Geo
yeah you're says I smash Steve Eisman
Iseman I'm a nice thing like a ergonomic
that's why I do it all the time
maybe just oh yeah Jonah's you can cuz
I've always the hose I'm always like
okay I need to like be presentable water
I'm like you know what this feels good
something I'm talking down to you I like
this you should do my horn like this I
used to like kneeling on my chair and
doing my homework like this I like this
I like lynnium guys feels good yeah kind
of nice all right continue right I agree
okay it's a doggy style ready take it up
that suddenly feel very bored overall
well I thought you got your doggy style
in the chair I thought the chairs taking
it oh yeah the chairs taking it you know
I'm sitting in a chair cowgirl in the
chair like the chairs facing Oh true I'm
getting ready to get my booty lick does
that mean when you normally sitting is
just a reverse cowgirl
oh yeah we're taking it up this chair
smells like sweaty just a sweaty Iceman
[Laughter]
smell like monster energy drink
someone's you know people's scalps first
of all all your shirts have a single
name on it mine's is the one that's
hoard around over here bro dude this
yeah we swap around all the time do you
think your essence gets blended into
things and cloth it does because last
night I slept over Nikki's house and she
let me borrow some PJ's and like as I
was putting it on like I could smell the
shirt and I'm like oh that's what Nikki
smells like that's funny how about other
people but I'm like I wonder what mine
smells like to them it just sounds like
a Nikki sense Gina
used my makeup sponge and it smelt like
Gina for like two weeks that's funny
yeah okay we're getting distracted I
have an amide the [ __ ] in front of
mother genus smell like she smells like
a cool aunt like you call it a little
like a mix of perfume and cigarettes
you're [ __ ] cool like you must go out
and have leather jacket
yeah leather jacket tape oh yeah and it
was when she was first you know she was
like going on dates and stuff
mmm cigarettes and like there ya know
it's just sort of smelled like well
maybe I shouldn't describe it like that
yeah maybe not like okay perfume and
leather okay
yeah like a designer handbag that's what
Gina smells like I can tell ya so Gina
mm-hmm okay
fact of it I can't party without the way
there's a card eh Anna hello everybody
my name is a party well cause last time
you parted it was still like not very
well everybody my name is up Hartke
that's all tight you get to be the
character with your real life I know I
didn't know my hair could even look like
this man would you guys be down and do a
revamp [ __ ] yeah
give me like eight months I grow my hair
up to Bart was the real one or the
uncles different I got to redo the uncle
cuz it just looks way too wacky and
fictional ya know you gotta keep it or
you can't be rebirth it it's like Dumb
and Dumber when they came out with the
three the third movie or the second
movie whatever it was like oh no we're
not that sucky though I mean what's the
story here finally yes yes cuz you're
the one who interrupted me my sorry it's
just I mean I'm right across from Joey
who's the [ __ ] I want to know tell me
you'll be okay so the title here says mi
REE [ __ ] for adding weird child-free
terminology to the swear jar list okay
so it says sweet let me sit down right
for this challenge
Last Man Standing okay you win
yeah good job this child free like GMO
like paraben free no MSG preservatives
or children didn't use kids to make this
show they should have that on Nike chow
free shoes they can't even say that
though I know cuz it cuz it's all made
my job yeah but do little hands are
really [ __ ] good at making iPhones
and [ __ ] so okay compared to kids though
alright I will start reading okay it
says my brother is child free and not in
the normal I don't want kids but I don't
hate them wait but in the weird way
where he Annika Lee uses words like
crotch goblins good fun and brats she
referred to my 13 year old son and 11
year 11 and 3 year old daughters my son
has started swearing within the last few
years and his younger sister is at an
age where she can pick it up while his
11 year old sister started swearing as
soon as he did I decided to institute a
swear jar and the money goes out of
their pocket let's see out of their
pocket money that they earned for doing
chores it's one pound per swear and my
husband and I also follow it my brother
got dumped by his long-term girlfriend a
couple weeks ago and is temporarily
staying with me while he finds a new
place he's in the he's in the guest room
right now and eager to move out because
he hates living with kids made more
urgent by the fact that I'm currently
five months pregnant so he doesn't want
to be here when the baby is born
my brother's aware of the swear jar and
he said he'd watch his mouth and has had
to pay a few times for referring to my
kids as [ __ ]
we had at least you don't have to worry
he's a pedophile yeah he's uh gotta make
it more expensive you know right I know
one pounds not enough uh she says we
have some non swear words on the swear
words list primarily insults like more
on Egypt idiot and while the kids are
allowed to joke with each other we're
trying to discourage use of insults I
caught my brother calling my kids things
like spawn and brats and even crotch
goblins and asked him directly to stop
using them he didn't stop and then I
heard my thirteen-year-old calling the
younger two brats and told me to deal
with your spawn the three-year-old so I
talked to my husband about it and we
decided to add the words he's using to
the list of swears nice I'm seeing them
added to the list my brother got really
angry accused me of trying to police his
language and treating him like a child
we told him they were added in light of
the thirteen year old using them but he
insisted the additions were for our
mainly my way of being
passive-aggressive towards him and
treating him like one of our kids
he says he'll speak how he wants as he's
an adult and won't put money in the
swear jar for those he is now demanding
an apology he's gotten mom involved who
has oh my god can I shouldn't be so
passive aggressive and should stop
trying to police the language of grown
adults and while my husband is on my
side
mom's siding with my brother has me
seriously doubting myself and might be
[ __ ]
nope is he paying rent exactly cuz like
I honestly if he's paying rent ya then
she's an [ __ ] but if he's not paying
rent dude nice pay rent like whose
[ __ ] house so he might be getting a
good deal on the rent or like he doesn't
have to stay there and I don't trust
anybody that don't like dogs and kids
those two things make me go something's
wrong with ya
but I lease off you yeah like I don't
know I also wait I don't know if he's
using like Jeannie uses it very
ironically like she she just like jokes
because she doesn't want to have kids
but what she's not even serious about
that yeah she's just like and do it
I think spawn is funny I think something
understand yeah don't be calling my kids
a brat you [ __ ] [ __ ] my finger yeah
Brett a lot brother calling my kids a
brat and like pissed about it and I do
even jokingly Truluck you cuz my mom
said it endearingly and the thing is
like okay if he knows that she's above
she she's pregnant she's about to pop
out another kid and she's already on his
way out like why is he such a [ __ ] like
me yeah leave well you know he's a
little [ __ ] when he's like I'm gonna
get mom involved if you treat me like a
child
i'ma go tell mom yeah when people that
okay I feel like the reason why you want
to be more successful is that you have
more power to do things like if you live
alone you don't if you don't like kids
that you don't have to [ __ ] deal with
this [ __ ] right but if you're if
someone's doing you a favor because
you're a [ __ ] broke ass you have to
suck it the [ __ ] up with things that you
don't like or else get more successful
and move the [ __ ] out exactly know has
no ground to stand on no and but people
are so entitled I'm like what's wrong
with you dude I hate people like that I
want to [ __ ] smack him across his
face and say [ __ ] and I put a dollar in
sighs you're setting a good example for
your children
yep I think so I think you'll see you
gotta put like a dollar 50 change at
that house I'll just wait for the best
conversion day yeah yeah today I would
just imagine if my kid came out to me I
was like I'm your brat
okay what the [ __ ] taught you that I
feel like I'm your spawn I'm like yeah
that's a good span how you doing spine
because of you I'm your crotch gum I
still be like who
that did you guys have words that
weren't customers that you weren't
allowed to use in the house cuz I had a
lot and I thought forever that they were
bad words really yeah like okay
I couldn't we couldn't say shut up we
couldn't say jerk we couldn't say suck
like into this sucks
or anything like that we couldn't say
what like if you were like like what you
gotta say pardon me oh yeah yeah you
can't say like that's so disrespectful I
can say all the words my mom didn't
understand any of them but she's like
you I could say like [ __ ] I could say I
just can't say stupid no consistent
funny because the worst words they
didn't understand so you could say is a
[ __ ] I think that's all I wanted but if
they could understand like whatever yeah
don't say that like you know home alone
was like look what you did you little
jerk
yeah was like oh that's such a bad word
like he don't ever say that I was like
he's that sure you got swearing for any
parents nowadays all its yeah my dad
cuts the most out of all of us
my dad's Cantonese so he never held back
when you were kids we had a swear jar
and he would always like he would
angrily like what you're saying like
jokingly he would ain't really do that
he'd be like [ __ ] anybody taking
his wallet he take $20 legs like take it
then take my parents my mom would hit me
if I said something bad but the hard
thing is I learned it from my dad and my
dad learned it from movies and the thing
is when I dad learns bad words from
movies when he gets mad all he does is
he thinks he just needs to stitch all
the bad words together and the more bad
words [ __ ] God [ __ ] [ __ ] that son
about that goddamn Isaac started to get
a little uncomfortable and what was it
that he said oh he's same damn dad a lot
yes like growing up like like in like a
very Christian community
is a very fancy Dan couldn't say he'll
he'll and damn burly man yeah but
nowadays I feel like it's not that bad
take God's name in vain no but like he's
a really good kid in front of it
obviously I mean who the [ __ ] knows what
he's doing with his friends but um in
front of us he's very good about like
censoring himself even though me and
Casey like we end up cussing a lot yeah
we cuss a lot yeah I mean we need a
swear jar we do how come you don't want
your kids cussing on the parents it's
your kid yeah so mainly a selfish thing
yeah that was like hey like we don't
want you getting comfortable saying
these words cuz then if you get
comfortable here like there's nothing I
like in a Lear ong with it but then it
slips out when your cuz you're
comfortable with it's a good philosophy
to like know the rules so you know one
to break them so know how to be
respectful and like the light so that
you know when you can yeah yeah there's
not this the one thing I hate the most
about being in public sometimes it's
being around people that are really free
with their cursing I like you here just
people gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I'm like read a [ __ ] stage there
and like there's like [ __ ] kids
everywhere [ __ ] child right here
do you literally get that one yeah we
were in a car and then you tell cuz who
was it I forgot he's David oh yeah David
even doesn't even know that he does is
they're so used to cussing they don't
even know they're doing wait you told
David too cuz like KC he's like you end
up getting to like a boiling point and
you explode oh you don't really like
after you it was right after you Harry
said something I was like oh man I
disrespectful for TIFF who's just trying
to like set a healthy cuz Isaac was
environment for Isaac and I think was
like five six yeah so I was just like
what the [ __ ] and then I just like blew
up on David out of nowhere no you're
like stop [ __ ] cussing in front of
the kid
have you guys seen the Lance Armstrong
document on ESPN
yeah so like we're trying not to cuss to
because Tigers out of age where he can't
even reason you can't even tell him why
it's a bad word so he just hears it and
you're just saying it I love it when he
comes we don't wanna go to preschool and
you start saying crazy [ __ ] and then
we're watching the Lance Armstrong
document in the first 30 seconds latched
on traffic and then like and so that was
like so we already have that rule and
really all this is pretty wholesome he's
a bike rider you know and then we hear
that and it not Tigers blow the stuff
[Music]
you gotta replace it I don't say [ __ ]
say [ __ ] [ __ ] he goes [ __ ] I knew what
I said
that's it merely [ __ ] him [ __ ] he's just
copying you 100% your fault
[Music]